rock paper scissors a simple hand game
dating back to the Han Dynasty of
Imperial China it is a decisive game
between two players with the only
outcomes being Win Lose or Draw we're
quite familiar with rock paper scissors
here at the SCP Foundation as the guards
are often seen playing intense rounds of
the game to determine who will be the
Unlucky Soul chosen to secure one of the
various ketter class as CPS during a
given week in most cases this use of
rock paper scissors is accepted as a
largely harmless and Fair Way for
defensive Personnel to arrange their
chefs the reason for this is that the
results of rock paper scissors are
generally random as there are very few
ways for an individual's skill to
influence the game or someone might
think in reality rock paper scissors is
a deeply psychological game and this is
mainly because of its origin as a
contest between fellow human beings the
average human is vulnerable to making
errors and falling into patterns and
with only three options to keep track of
it is entirely possible for a seasoned
veteran of rock paper scissors to
predict their opponent's Choice before
any hands are thrown of course that
opponent may also commit an error of
their own by misreading the other
player's actions and thus there is
always a chance for an impulsive
decision to swing the results of the
game in either direction human
limitation is the only skill based
mechanic in the game of rock paper
scissors and that same limitation is
what in the eyes of some holds the game
back from reaching its true potential
that was the case until someone out
there discovered the rules to an
anomalous version of rock paper scissors
being spread through a mysterious email
while all attempts to trace the email
back to its original sender have left
the foundation with more questions than
answers we have been able to learn more
about the differences between the rules
of standard rock paper scissors and the
anomalous version we have given this
anomalous version of rock paper scissors
the designation
scp-4633 and unlike the classic edition
under no circumstances are any
foundation Personnel allowed to play a
game incorporating any of the
alternative rules while the ceiling for
skill and variety is theoretically much
higher in a rock paper scissors match
featuring
scp-4633 the risks to the player far
outweigh any added novelty here is how
scp-4633 functions during an average
game of rock paper scissors well average
prior to the anomalous properties taking
effect rather than being limited to
using merely rock paper or scissors as
the name of the game implies the players
gain access to a series of additional
hand gestures which upon the act of
being thrown becomes seamlessly
integrated into both players shared
understanding of the rules this alone
would be bizarre enough for the true
harm caused by scp-4633 is in the nature
of the gestures themselves when one of
the non-standard gestures Allowed by
scp-4633 is used the player's hands will
change shape in ways that under normal
circumstances would be anatomically
impossible each of these non-standard
gestures is distinct from the rest with
the only commonality being an unusual
tendency for the final gesture to
resemble biological structures often
seen in sea life one particular gesture
might cause a player to rapidly grow a
ring of additional fingers surrounding a
gaping anemone like mouth in the Palm
while another could result in the
player's entire arm flattening into a
fin-like appendage regardless of how
severe a departure from a typical human
limb the final gesture would be the
limbs and on rare occasions the entire
body of the player using the gesture
will quickly end irreversibly mutate
into the shape required to successfully
perform it while these gestures
overwhelmingly result in forms that
would be distressing to most people the
same cognitive effect that causes the
participants to accept changes to the
rules also appears to apply to the
changes affecting their own bodies to
the players of an scp-4633 augmented
match of rock paper scissors the
non-standard gestures seem as mundane as
the original Three unfortunately the
morphic properties of scp-4633 are
practically irreversible with extreme
reconstructive surgery being required in
even the best of cases in all instances
of
scp-4633 surgical intervention is
necessary to prevent the spread of
details regarding the non-standard
gestures and their usage because of the
immediate shift in cognitive awareness
among participants all that is needed
for a new instance of scp-4633 to occur
is the faintest hint of knowledge of the
alternative rules it's even been noted
that between different groups of players
the non-standard gestures can vary
heavily or seemingly be created on the
fly as the desire to win at all costs
takes hold here are a few examples of
anomalous gestures which have been
observed during instances of
scp-4633 this list is by no means
comprehensive but it will provide an
insight into how
scp-4633 drastically Alters the existing
mechanics of the game as well as the
physique of the players the Thor Riley
gesture transforms the user's fingers
into Barbed tentacles it beats paper and
scissors but loses to rock chavoga folds
the fingers of the hand into the palm
and causes them to emerge through the
back of the Palm it allows the user to
throw a second gesture after they've
seen their opponent's Choice ashkelhas
splits the hand into a pair of poisonous
Stingers which also produce a potent
electrical current between them it has
been seen to lose to paper but seemingly
of their own will The Stingers lashed at
the opposing player and caused them to
fall unconscious three rounds later due
to the effects of the poison Chau sub
beats paper and two other anomal
gestures loses to scissors rock and a
third gesture and morphs the user's arm
into a Dactyl Club similar to the front
appendage of a mantis shrimp the zergov
simply causes the player to grow three
additional thumbs on one hand the final
gesture resembles a triple thumbs up his
urugov has not been seen to beat any
gestures and the player who uses it
always seems to go on to lose the match
pagakumar causes the middle and ring to
recede into the hand while the pointer
and pinky fingers extend to resemble the
eye stalks of a snail or slug the rest
of the hand also becomes coated in a
thin layer of slime which continues to
secrete from within pagakmar beats
scissors and paper but loses to Rock and
Another anomalous gesture known as
vayonjik incidentally Ryon Jack causes
the arm of the player using it to
elongate into a worm-like tube that
periodically spews a gout of salt water
on the opponent when vyanchek was seen
beating pagakmar the saltwater appeared
to have some adverse effect on the
ladder gesture causing the eye stocks to
droop and the hand to shrivel until it
was half its original size another
anomalous gesture is grazothrog
recognized by the skin muscle and veins
of the hand turning translucent
revealing a pulsing red organ in the
interior of the Palm once grasathrag has
been thrown the player who used it may
call out the name of one other gesture
which can no longer be used in the
current match the ukayag gesture is a
bit deceptive as it resembles Rock when
first thrown but gradually causes the
hand to condense into a lump of inert
material not dissimilar to actual
igneous rock the knuckles as well begin
to exude a superheated mineral substance
similar to molten lava ukayog
exclusively beats paper and appears to
lose to everything else many of the
gestures on record have no known name
but their function within
scp-4633's altered rules is clear from
the context in which they were used such
is the case with one anomalous gesture
which caused most of the player's hand
to withdraw into a siphon-like opening
at their wrist before the very same
orifice shot out a stream of ink into
the opposing player's eyes while there
was no lasting harm done to the opponent
by this gesture the ink did cause
temporary blindness which persisted
until they were defeated by way of their
Rock losing to paper another unknown
gesture has been seen beating both
izorogov and ukayag this gesture makes
the player's hand resemble the crest and
gas-filled body of a Pacific Mana War
these examples are only scraping the
surface of these seemingly Endless
Possibilities that scp-4633 has to offer
as you can see the anomalous hand
gestures can be just as dangerous within
the game itself as the permanent changes
they invoke in the user while the
foundation has done its best to contain
all information surrounding
scp-4633 there have been clear efforts
by several unknown groups to push the
game into continued usage over the past
three decades in instances of scp-4633
have seen increasing popularity in the
world of high-stakes gambling Perhaps it
is because of the inherent thrill of
watching two opponents trying to
strategically outwit each other with a
countless number of non-standard
gestures but more likely it is part of
the anomalous effect of
scp-4633 that the game would appeal to
those desperate to risk everything on
the slim chance of Victory this neatly
brings us to the scp-4633 related
incident which occurred aboard the
private ocean liner known as the SS
fateful Emma before the incident the
Fateful Emma would sail into
international waters twice a year each
time it would bring along a new group of
passengers seemingly selected from the
underprivileged and downcast sector of
society a great many of these passengers
were convicts with repeat violent
offenses chosen from supermax facilities
the world over the process by which
these inmates were chosen for a voyage
aboard the ship was not dissimilar from
the methods the the foundation uses to
acquire new class D Personnel naturally
this was how the research team was able
to be tipped off about the Fateful Emma
it became apparent soon after looking
into the ship's career that the
individuals altered by the effects of
scp-4633 had been seen departing from
the ship on multiple occasions in remote
island Harbors most of the time the
individuals would also be to the best of
their ability with their metamorphized
forms carrying briefcases filled with
hundreds of thousands of dollars in cash
while Witnesses tend to write off the
strange appearances of those affected as
being the result of a deformity or
injury or more pronounced instances
dismissing the encounters as sightings
of creatures from the local mythology it
was clear to anyone familiar with
scp-4633 what was truly going on these
passengers were being made to play
pitched games of rock paper scissors
featuring
scp-4633 for massive sums of wealth and
what was worse the grand prize winners
were seemingly being released back into
civilization without the knowledge of
law enforcement of course what the
foundation was most concerned about was
the potential for the large-scale leak
of detailed information involving
scp-4633 it seemed that the foundation's
latest faceless enemy had revealed
itself whatever wealthy group of
individuals was pulling the strings
behind the games aboard the SS fateful
Emma it was very likely that the ship
was also well protected by a private
Army of trained mercenaries in a display
of Swift but necessary initiative the
foundation assembled a brand new mobile
task force to be dispatched onto the
ocean liner mobile task force row 52
with the fitting code name Rochambeau
the mobile task force would board The
Vessel secretly and use whatever means
necessary to prevent the spread of
scp-4633 and any evidence of the
associated non-standard hand gestures
before the Fateful Emma's next Voyage
the foundation isolated the poor Port
where it would depart from and made sure
that the MTF agents were in position the
operation was co-captained by agent
DuBois and agent Shang both of whom
prided themselves on having
extraordinarily good luck agent Dubois
would stealthily move the majority of
the agents under his command into the
cargo hold below deck and await agent
Zhang's signal agent Zhang himself would
assume the name and identity of one of
the criminal passengers who was
intercepted before boarding by the
mobile task force the would-be
participant was subsequently detained
and brought into the foundation as a
Class D personnel as the SS faithful
Emma began to leave the harbor ajin
Zhang joined the other passengers who
had been gathered together in an
enormous function hall there was little
indication of when the games would begin
and Zhang made an effort to keep a low
profile until more information was
available shortly after the ship had
officially arrived in international
waters an eccentric man entered the room
on a walkway that overlooked the rest of
the passengers he was flanked by a pair
of armed bodyguards it was playing from
the man's style of dress and demeanor
that he was both absurdly wealthy and
completely out of his mind he wore a
pure white tuxedo and a scarf that
seemed to have been made from the fur of
a Siberian tiger a pair of Dark Shades
with sequined rims obscured his eyes
from view but by far the strangest
aspect of the rich man was the fact that
emerging from the wrist of his right arm
was the eyeless head of Amore eel where
his hand should be the man spoke
addressing the entire room welcome
passengers new and old to the SS fateful
Emma while you aboard this ship your
fate is in your own hands over the next
24 hours you will have the rare
opportunity to play the greatest game of
chance that Humanity has ever known
generations of people from every
continent and every Walk of Life have
given their all to the Mastery of rock
paper scissors across nosbach or slashes
the man proceeded to speak unused usual
syllables for the next minute straight
without even a pause for breath in his
report agent Zhang described the man's
voice as gaining an increasingly loud
hum as his speech continued and that
some of the syllables didn't seem to be
the product of human vocal cords he soon
concluded his string of gibberish and
resumed speaking intelligible language
as is customary we will be utilizing the
iljesh toei rules you will Begin by
selecting a single opponent and
challenging them to a best of two of
three match this is a single elimination
tournament and any competitors who
cannot otherwise continue to engage in
matches will also be eliminated by the
end of your time here the luckiest among
you will be named the Undisputed
champion of these games and will be
granted unlimited Freedom along with the
cash prize the rest of you will have to
determine your own Fates where you all
know what awaits you below may your
hands be ready your minds be sharp and
remember winning
is everything with a flourish of his
moray eel ham the wealthy man finished
his introductions and promptly exited
the room ajin Zhang looked at the
passengers surrounding him and saw that
they were already beginning to play Rock
Paper Scissors with each other a few had
already begun using the anomalous
gestures warping their limbs into
hideous subnautical shapes agent Zhang
gave the signal to agent DuBois and the
rest of the mobile task force to begin
the operation their target was primarily
the Moray handed man as well as any
other Close Associates that he had on
board they would capture him alive and
interrogate him into revealing the
mystery behind this illegal gambling
ring once the mercenaries were dealt
with agent Dubois team would further
command the ocean liner and navigate it
to SCP Foundation research site-45 to
await further orders as for agent Zhang
he knew what he had to do to buy time he
would participate in the ensuing rock
paper scissors tournament and eliminate
as many of the other players as possible
people this he believed was the best way
to minimize the number of anomalous
gestures that would be used aboard the
ship of course he himself wouldn't be
using any of the anomalous gestures
either opting to limit himself to the
standard three this could put him at a
severe disadvantage over the course of
the competition but agent Zhang knew
better than to tempt fate still being
eliminated seemed like something he may
want to avoid even though the
consequences for elimination were left
vague in these strange rich man's speech
he still didn't feel that it would be
wise to put himself in a compromised
position while aboard the Fateful Emma
bracing himself for the worst agent
Chang accepted the challenge of a nearby
passenger he was off to a promising
start when he threw a scissors hand
against his opponent's paper because the
matches were best two out of three all
he needed was to win one of the next two
matches and he'd survive this round then
he saw the devious look on his
opponent's face and he knew that this
match was about to get weird rather than
admit feet agent Zhang prepared to throw
scissors again the two challenged their
hands and just as Zhang had feared his
opponent threw an anomalous gesture
almost instantly the opponent's hand
took on a multi-melt piscene form which
began to spit sharp teeth in agent
Zhang's Direction fortunately the
agent's bulletproof vest was able to
withstand the impact of the teeth what
was even more fortunate was the fact
that the opponent seemed to be a good
sport scissors beats azravak U.N said
the other passenger before walking away
in search of their next match curiously
the passengers transformed arm continued
to fire teeth across the room at random
intervals occasionally hitting and
causing injury to one of the other
competitors agent Zhang was grateful
that the body armor he was wearing had
been tested to withstand rapid fire from
scp-127 compared to the raw power of the
living gun the teeth launched from
asrovok gestures were practically DB
rounds he had succeeded in not being
eliminated both from the game and and
generally excited about his win Zhang
sought out another opponent to test his
lock below deck agent DuBois and the
rest of the mobile task force had just
finished facing off against some of the
hired mercenaries when they entered a
room presumed to be the ocean liners
sickbay inside was a grisly sight a
second rock paper scissors tournament
playing out between players that had
been so thoroughly transformed by the
anomalous gestures of
scp-4633 that they barely appeared to
still be human it was like a scene from
a deep sea documentary with strange and
unknowable creatures vying for dominance
not within a natural food chain or
competition for resources but within a
seemingly never-ending struggle to win a
game of chance it was Purgatory rock
paper scissors Purgatory agent DuBois
was appalled but he knew better than to
attempt to stop these creatures from
doing the one thing keeping them all
distracted the more a-handed man was
still somewhere in the ship and
capturing him was far more important the
research team would decide what to do
with these former humans once the ship
was Secure within the foundation's
custody however what agent Dubois didn't
realize is that some of these creatures
were advancing on his team in
nightmarish and on Earthly voices they
chanted rock rock paper scissors
suddenly one of the Abominations
resembled nothing more closely than an
enormous mass of coral produce Four Arms
from within its body and began to throw
anomalous hand signs towards the agents
one of the arms threw akyag which coded
an unsuspecting agent in hot lava
causing him to drop to the floor in pain
Panic Dubois ordered the task force to
eliminate every living thing in the
sickbay although not in the sense of
their tournament standing of course
meanwhile ajin Zhang was on a win streak
in the function hall through sheer luck
and determination he had managed to
avoid elimination while eliminating
several other passengers himself he
began to notice that those who were
eliminated were quietly escorted way by
the bouncers seeming to have their
anomalous changes treated now it was
only down to 12 remaining passengers
agent Zhang knew that it was only a
matter of time before DuBois and his
team took control of the ship but
feeling Reckless he challenged one of
the remaining passengers in that moment
something came over him as if his
determination to see the mission through
was also compelling him to win at any
cost his opponent threw pagakmar and out
of instinct Zhang through vanyanjak the
agent went on to win the entire
tournament but sadly he was unable to
collect the prize money as during the
Skirmish below deck the man with the
Moray hand had escaped with a small
fortune in a high-speed submersible his
ultimate goals and the scope of the
shadowy group he represented would
remain unanswered for the time being
when the SS fateful Emma finally arrived
at site-45 agent Zhang came to his
senses and realized that he had
underestimated the cognitive side
effects of
scp-4633 due to the immediately
recognizable anomalous state of both his
arms agent Zhang was later contained on
site with minimal security it's believed
that researchers are still searching for
a method to reverse the effects it just
goes to show that winning isn't
everything now go check out scp-439 bone
Hive and
scp-3989 the bone Orchard for more
terrifying Tales of body horror